welcome to GameSpot stage for e3 2016
i'm lucy o'brien from the future the
years have not been kind
I'm joined by two more Hussein and also
jf and Jonathan we're gonna be talking
about Deus Ex mankind divided the sexes
it's such an exciting and really
interesting stealth game what are you
guys showing off here that's new at e3
well today we're going to show the first
map of the game which is called Dubai so
it's the beginning exposing the the
setting the the fantasy of the character
Adam Jensen and like basically
establishing the new world that they're
going to wear at Jensen is going to
evolve and the second map or the second
video we're going to show is the the
breach mode the new a gameplay mode that
we we revealed last week yeah so what
what is it that happens in Dubai what
how is the world changed since the last
time that we saw Adam Jensen well by the
end of human Revolution there was a big
incident where a lot of augmented
citizens went crazy and they turn into
zombie mode should we say and a lot of
people die and and now we're two years
after those events and now the dust is
settling down a little bit but there are
still a lot of tension a lot of people
from both sides like Naturals are
fearing the Augmented citizens and
they're trying to pass laws and
segregative laws and put the people in
ghettos and stuff like that and now you
have also augmented citizen that are
trying to make their voice heard and
they're fighting back and Adam Jensen is
going to be in the middle of this world
is working now for task force 29 which
is a subdivision of Interpol and they're
it's an anti anti terrorist group that
is trying to bring some some peace to
the world and also Adam Jensen's
motivation to be in that it's to do some
good but also he believes that this
agency is tied to some people in the
shadows the Illuminati that are steering
the the society in the direction that
maybe doesn't agree with so he wants to
stop them it's something that you guys
compared to apartheid which of course is
a horrible and tragic thing and how do
you meld those two things together both
having a powerful and an interesting
message well
so making a fun and interesting game to
play it's a good question what we do
first and foremost we're trying to make
a good game we're trying it's a
fictional world we're trying to create
an experience that players are going to
dig and everything and after that we
always try to have interesting questions
an interesting theme to explore so
players can be immersed in the world can
have fun with the mechanics and enjoy a
great adventure but at the same time we
put a lot of layers trying to show like
that the different angles of a subject
and let the players choose by themselves
like what they think like which we try
to stay neutral we're not trying to say
this is good this is bad this is this
this is that it's really all about
putting the players in the middle of
this world and ask them questions and
let the players find their own answers
and I don't think we're comparing it to
the apartheid I wouldn't put it this way
I mean I think by default there is a bit
you know the moment that you use a term
or something has already been used maybe
by default we can or you can argue that
there is a comparison to be to be made
but I mean us it's not like the the will
is not to compare it to it what has
already happened but what the meaning of
an apartheid is is a really really good
fit kind of politically speaking for
what the politics and the game you know
so that that's that's really what it is
right and it's a good fit and it's it's
science fiction science fiction has
always been about you know kind of
talking about really serious themes and
whatnot in a projected setting but to
kind of get people to think about their
current issues and their inner
contemporary world you can see some of
the by here and obviously Dubai itself
as it currently is is quite an
interesting visual city was kind of your
like approach going into reinventing it
for like a futuristic sci-fi well our
our goal with Dubai was to kind of
bridge the gap between human Revolution
and mankind divided lifes really what
the map is yeah yeah and in the last
game the Icarus myth was a big myth that
we were using to tell the story of human
Revolution where augmentations were like
the the the future it was the bright
future
Oh what we can be so golden age
enlightenment exactly party exactly and
so Icarus like with his wings
augmentations trying to fly high getting
too close to the Sun eventually burning
his wing and falling into the sea and
now with mankind divided it's kind of
like we're ending the Icarus myth by
Adam Jensen is in Dubai it's very black
and go there's the sunset and now for
his first mission like we saw a few
seconds ago is jumping down like like
he's jumping into the sea to start his
mission it really represents the ending
of human revolution exactly like all the
you know we've had too much fun you know
we went too far okay now we're just
crashing down parties over parties and
so yeah so that's it it's kind of
foreshadowing what's coming in two men
kind of idea that it's going to be a
little bit more darker and the new art
style so is going to what we call
corporate feudalism like where
everything is a little bit more it's
based on Brutalism and and yes like that
and it's all about showing that the
world is taking a step back and is
refusing the new world or basically the
the Augmented world and everything so
that is to bridge the gap between it
looks like it sets the table there's
gonna be a lot of like conflict
happening in this one because as you say
it's kind of it's all coming to a head
which must make it really exciting and
interesting to create these like stealth
scenarios that are kind of avoid
avoiding these conflicts and working
around them so what's gonna be like
approach to ensuring that people who
would like to avoid conflict are well
cared for in a game that seems to be you
know putting lots of combat into it or
brain clashes between different groups
and in question yeah well actually what
is important to us it's to let the
players play the way they want like we
have our two primary pillars that were
combat and stealth and sorry and we have
the secondary modes that are hacking and
social and for us it's really really
important to make sure that players can
play the way they want and when I say
the way they want it's not just out or
combat but it's killing or not killing
or even just that we avoid confrontation
at all so because you could do stealth
and kill yes and you can be combat and
not kill a go and fight and not and not
kill anyone yeah
you know put everybody to sleep and
neutralized them with yeah yeah
the Tesla gun you know he's gonna think
yeah that's that's one of the thing that
we wanted to do with this game with the
John what he just said the fact that we
we want to make stealth and combat more
intertwined together in the sense that
and if you look at human Revolution a
lot of the tools you add that your
disposal whether it was augmentations or
or weapons that their their behaviors
like let's see some of the stealth ones
or the non-lethal one was kind of
forcing you or was more useful when you
were stealthy but in combat you would
have failed for mankind divided like you
just said like with the gun arms now we
have yes the Nano blade that is little
but we have the the pepsin gun arm we
have the Tesla gun arm which are totally
non-lethal weapons and you can go in the
free and use them and just not
unconscious people and continue so and
then back to your guns if you end up
eggs everything is a lot more like
wholesome it's a lot it's a lot more
holistic this kind of this can I call it
like the ballet of like going between
your arms and your weapons or just
staying to your arms or whatever and use
them non-lethal or lethal and everything
just kind of intertwined very very well
which is a thing we didn't really have
in humor exactly so it was really
important to offer more choices within
the same realm of possibilities as human
it just flows so much yeah what kind of
choices do you guys make when you play
do you have a preference for going
stealth or for going just all-out guns
blazing like I'm the kind of guy I'm
like the the stealthy killer I guess I
like to just kind of infiltrate and you
know it's a very kind of Metal Gear
Solid approach right it's gonna
infiltrate making sure I don't get
noticed or whatever and but still kind
of take people down and that's what I do
and may I try I'm still t2 but I'm
trying to to avoid people as much as I
can and just take down take down the
ones I feel I have to take down but I
don't kill them and that just brings my
way through and I explore everything and
making sure that I find all the little
secrets readable whatever I play usually
I play quite stealthy but this games
like for example it's not a stealth game
but Mass Effect but I usually try and
play as a Paragon and then every now and
then I encounter a character which I
dislike so much stuff
so I bend my rules now and then and do
you kind of like as a developer do you
think about that and you build into the
game do you try and you know put in
these situations where you know we want
to try and create a character that kind
of upsets the players who would
traditionally be kind of docile and
trying to avoid combat to get them to
engage in other types of systems do you
think about that well I question yeah I
think our approach is more first and
foremost what we want is to create
interesting characters that you will
love to hate or just love or maybe hate
to love and our goal yeah it's more to
create those those different characters
and one thing that we always say is that
in our world nothing is black or white
it's all shades of grey so we're always
trying to build complex characters that
have good sides and bad sides and we're
all different human beings and we we
don't like all the same stuff so some
characters for you might be like I want
to punch it but for some other people
know this person is actually like a good
person and I like her or in 4xy reasons
kind of thing and I would probably
generate what you're talking about
by creating good characters you know
that have like real world not real
personalities but like good artificial
personalities or whatever probably
everybody will eventually find someone
it's just like it's like a Frank
Pritchard in the last game yeah yeah a
lot of people like we're hating him but
some other people know when you think
about that it's one of the few
characters throughout the entire game
that doesn't lie to you via a react is
really least a guy you can trust yeah
that is an [ __ ] or way not you know
the police guy we all here because it
was so weak and so whiny
but it wasn't planned that well yeah so
one of my favorite characters who I'm
wondering is gonna wear a shoe make a
return is the tissue the trash lady you
remember her yeah one of my favorite
things about games with choice
especially like The Witcher or Mass
Effect or your ability to romance
characters as well and you know that's a
way to interact with characters is that
something you ever thought about
introducing in some way into the Deus Ex
franchise against you know make love our
fans are so good at creating those
romance
you know that after the fact you know
Deus Ex Human Revolution fan are you're
gonna see something pretty horror some
good stuff and some horrible you want to
turn States yeah actually we we were
it's something that we discuss and
everything but for the kind of game we
were going and the things that were
exploring we didn't want to this track
and go in two directions that in the end
like it doesn't necessarily helps the
purpose of telling the story we want to
tell and everything so we we talk about
that but for us it was not necessarily
bringing something super important to
what we're trying to do and therefore we
didn't do that
this is your new breach mode right yes
that's that's bridge it's a new gameplay
mode and what is cool with that is that
we wanted to to use the core mechanics
of of the sx and we wanted to have a
fresh spin on it like i have a new kind
of arcade twist where it's just simple
fast running and puzzle solving and and
everything and also we wanted to have a
fresh look a different visual style
explore something i never leaned on a
new art direction exactly yeah and for
us it was kind of like one of our lines
when we developed it's we want to break
expectations and for us bridge mode was
a way to do that so it ties even though
it's left feel a bit it's kind of a
virtual reality world where corporations
are storing their and private
information' and everything and you play
a ripper which is kind of a hacker into
the virtual world and there are kind of
like the digital digital era kind of
Robin Hood's and they're trying to
really expose the truth about all those
corporations to keep the the world a
better place to keep those corporations
more in line and not abusing of their
power and stuff like that so there's a
basic premise and a story lines in there
that you can unravel but it's especially
built around like the fun game playing
the pure
arcade experience and there's a social
component to it where you can challenge
friends like you can send them a map
with different modifiers different
conditions to win the map and if your
friend accept the challenge and wins it
gets the point and it climbs up in the
leaderboard or if if he fails you get
the points and you climb but so it's
really fun and that that dual thing is
what I really and what I really really
like about breach as well because it's
more like bite sized a little kind of
game play environments and whatnot and
because it's it's using kind of the same
mechanics of the main game the same kind
of augmentations and whatever what I
like is if you're let's say like a
stealth player right when you play
mankind divided and you're you're mostly
having a stealth build right of stuff
Adam well then if you go if you go play
breach the cool thing is that now you
might start indulging into the more
offense can often Skanda kind of
augmentations and one and have fun with
that without affecting the build you
have in the main game and also it's our
first live mode we're going to collect
the data from players as they play so
we'll be able to to find some stuff it
if needs be and also we have extra
content that is going to be unleash
after the release of the game which is
nice as well and it seems like you know
introducing this kind of technology have
you have you guys thought about virtual
reality at selfie rooms something that
ties both into this world and there's a
really big theme for 2016 yes actually
we have we're going to release a
benchmark tool this summer and it's
supposed to come with a virtual reality
experience like just like exploring some
of the environments of mankind divided
like can as a gift to the fans of superh
and just being in yeah it's more like a
museum mode like there's no gameplay and
it has like two environments that you
can walk through but I mean I'd be
totally lying to you guys if I were to
tell you that I - Montreal doesn't have
virtual reality kits and that we haven't
played with them or whatever but but of
course if a developer now this and
doesn't have them it's gonna so you know
something something happened I don't
know
what but I'm gonna leave it at that for
now Fisher ojf John thanks so much for
for taking the time and walking us
through Deus Ex mankind divided and for
even more excitement and Deus Ex action
here at e3 2016 stay tuned to game spot
com you're watching the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airheads